[Music]
you have a lot of toys you have more
toys than most adults i know i make a
toy show so i know you make a show with
toys but every time i hang around you
you've got all these like action figures
toys legos does this make are you good
interacting with kids that's misleading
to say every time you hang around with
me i'm covered in toys but yes uh i like
to they're spilling out of you
i'm like hey you know you take something
out of your pocket and and toys and
jelly beans spill out
but but i do think i'm all right with
kids i mean i they they don't run
screaming from me or anything like that
i got nieces and nephews and they're
they're fun but strangers give me their
kids all the time we've talked about
this before but it's still current
whenever i meet people they'll be like
oh take a picture with my baby hold my
baby
here get close i get that too they hold
you everybody
their baby they don't know who we are as
real people it's so irresponsible like
if you look at most of the roles i've
played i'm like some affable slacker guy
who doesn't work hard at his job and
would probably accidentally drop your
baby right but people are always like
hold my most precious asset and i'm like
i'm gonna take a picture with your baby
i guess and i usually try and do
something really disturbing like put the
baby's hand in my mouth like i'm eating
your baby
what are you doing you pretend to
cannibalize the baby no i
look didn't your grandma always say oh
your face so cute i'm gonna eat your
face up like that's disturbing right now
no relative ever tried to eat my face or
threatened to eat my face somebody in
the audience see who's with me here
right
everyone clapping has a piece of their
face missing
you can't see that they're like
big chunk right there all the extras
from the walking dead in the audience
yeah
you uh you tweeted a picture recently
that you said gives you hope about one
day having children well this is true
this is the dax thing so dax shepard is
a buddy of mine uh and both of us when
we work together we we really we talk
like maybe we shouldn't breed because
individually all of our attributes when
passed on to a child could be horrible
so we thought oh we need to really uh
marry somebody stunning your wife is
gorgeous she is pretty so it kind of
evens the levels the playing field a
little bit um but dax actually tweeted
this picture of this australian hair
model that looks like one of your old if
they mated things like you and me and
dax shepard yeah this is if you and dax
shepard had a child yeah there he is yes
i see that
who is that guy this is this this is
this incredibly successful australian
hair model
i think i'm in love i know
so so dax found that picture and he was
like buddy the science is accurate it
looks like the fusion is complete we've
made our spawn
and uh and i said oh that guy's not half
bad looking maybe
maybe jackson i should procreate
no that doesn't work you gotta worry
like that no i thought it meant this oh
let them try